archie of course has just turned two so
what a wonderful belated birthday
present for him the arrival of a little
sister he was by all accounts so excited
about the baby
growing in mummy's tummy and i can
imagine that um he's probably one very
excited little two-year-old at the
moment
and the novelty of a new baby in the
house is one that i think is going to
stay with the whole family
for quite a long time lily bert is the
first
royal child in the line of royal
succession to be born in america
and therefore have dual citizenship
american citizenship because of her
mother and her birthplace
and british citizenship because of harry
and she
is also due a title but not until prince
charles is king
so as the son of a monarch harry's
children will be entitled
to take a royal title but of course
whether or not they will choose to take
it is another matter
these two have decided not to use their
hrh statuses
this is all part of them forging a new
life in california
personally i think it would be very
unlikely that they will want titles for
either archie
or lillybet because they have left the
royal family they are no longer working
members of the royal family
they don't use their royal titles why
would they want world titles for their
children
i'm sure titles is certainly something
that megan and harry will have discussed
but i think that given their decision to
stand down as senior members of the
royal
family and in doing so losing their
right to use their hrh statuses
i can't see that them wanting their
children to have loyal titles
is high on their list of priorities i
think far more important for them is
that their children can live
ordinary private lives of course with
harry and megan
we don't expect them to do the staged
photo call outside the hospital you know
they've really shunned royal traditions
when it comes to
the birth of their children and but one
thing they are doing is
taking joint parental leave and i think
that really is quite reflective of the
thoroughly modern couple that they are
it's not just a case
of megan taking maternity leave they're
both taking a couple of weeks off
to really enjoy this special time and i
think we will get a picture
but we're certainly not going to get a
sort of staged picture that we associate
with royal babies i think as with
everything harry and megan do
they'll do it their way when they're
ready on their turn